President Trump is in France this
morning still facing many questions
about Russia before the president and
first lady arrived in Paris he talked
for the first time in public about his
recent meeting with Russian President
Vladimir Putin and he defended his son
Donald Jr for meeting with campaign
chairman Paul Manafort son-in-law Jared
Kushner and a Russian lawyer trying to
who was going to give dirt about Hillary
Clinton Margaret Brennan is at the White
House Margaret good morning good morning
while in contradiction to his son's own
emails President Trump said Vladimir
Putin wanted Hillary Clinton not him to
win the 2016 election if Hillary had won
our military would be decimated our
energy would be much more expensive
that's what Putin doesn't like about me
in an interview with televangelist Pat
Robertson president Trump gave a
positive review of his first encounter
last week with Russian President
Vladimir Putin I think we got along very
well and I think that's a good thing
that's not a bad thing in another
interview the president said he asked
Putin about Russian hacking to influence
the 2016 election quote I said did you
do it and he said no I did not I then
asked him a second time in a totally
different way he said absolutely not US
intelligence services concluded with
high confidence that Russia interfered
emails released Tuesday by Donald Trump
jr. reference Russian government
attempts to help mr. Trump win and a
June 2016
Trump Tower meeting with a Kremlin link
lawyer who offered to share potentially
damaging information on Hillary Clinton
president Trump insisted that he only
learned of it a few days ago but did not
fault his son I think many people would
have held that meeting the president
said the meeting had been arranged by
publicist Rob Goldstone on behalf of a
russian pop star Emin our Ghulam whose
father is wealthy oligarch with ties to
Vladimir Putin
in video obtained by CNN mr. Trump can
be seen with all three men in Las Vegas
ahead of the 2013 Miss Universe pageant
an outside White House adviser described
recent revelations as the political
equivalent of quote a category 5
hurricane holding mostly closed-door
meetings this week like this one with
evangelical leaders laying their hands
on him in prayer President Trump insists
that the White House is functioning
perfectly
the White House said the president has
spoken with his son in recent days an
attorney for the president also denied
reports that he is trying to build a
wall between himself and anyone who
could potentially be in legal jeopardy
for their knowledge of and their
participation in that meeting such as
son-in-law Jared Kushner Jeff Margaret
thank you very much